uh good afternoon everybody
um
James my friend we've been uh around the
world together on many occasions already
uh
everywhere from New York to Munster to
Bucharest just in recent uh recent
months but it's a special pleasure to
have you here at the state department
for the first time in your current role
and we're adding another chapter
to a very long history of this special
relationship at a time when it could not
be more important and could not be more
more vibrant in each of these
engagements our shared work to confront
the threats posed by President Putin's
War regression against Ukraine I was at
the top of the agenda as it was today
both President Biden and prime minister
sunak have committed to standing with
Ukraine for as long as it takes and our
teams are in lockstep as we coordinate
our efforts both with one another and
also with our many allies and partners
we remain committed to sustaining our
security assistance to Ukraine as it
defends its people against Russia's
brutal attacks like the one we saw just
this weekend on an apartment building
in nepro uh on Saturday
far from the front lines
the census attack was launched from a
missile designed to sink ships
and killed dozens of people
wounded scores more
the youngest was just three years old
we applaud the prime minister's
commitment over the weekend to send
Challenger two tanks and additional
artillery systems to Ukraine elements
that will continue to reinforce and add
to what the United States has provided
including in our most recent drawdown
we remain United in strengthening our
humanitarian assistance to the Ukrainian
people
especially as President Putin continues
to weaponize Winter by attacking
Ukraine's electricity grid
through the G7 we're working with the
United Kingdom and other partners to
help Ukraine repair restore and defend
that grid
and we joined in applying economic
pressure through coordinated sanctions
and Export controls on Moscow holding
President Putin and his enablers
accountable imposing costs designed to
deprive Russia of the resources it needs
to keep fueling its War Machine
we're undertaking these efforts and more
to put Ukraine in the strongest possible
position when a negotiating table
emerges so that there can be a just and
durable peace that is our common
objective
the same time the Russian military
attacks Ukraine's energy supplies
Putin is using energy to try to punish
countries that support Ukraine
we're working together in several ways
to ensure that these efforts fail as
well
we're increasing the supply of liquefied
natural gas in the United States of the
United Kingdom
we've improved information sharing on
ways to strengthen the market for Energy
Smart appliances or investing in
developing and deploying new Clean
Energy Technologies all across Europe
in the face of these challenges
it's striking that many citizens of the
United Kingdom and across the continent
are rationing their energy use
taking quicker showers
lowering their heat
they understand the stakes of this war
and they too stand in solidarity with
Ukraine
the foreign secretary and I also had an
opportunity to discuss Iran we stand
with the British government in
condemning Iran's execution of Iranian
British dual National Ali razakbari
which was politically motivated and
unjust
if it's a pattern of abuse by the regime
detentions
torture forced confessions unjust
executions
we'll continue to work with the United
Kingdom and our allies and partners to
hold Iran's leadership accountable for
these and other abuses we'll keep
standing with the brave Iranians who are
standing up for their own basic rights
led by young women
all of this in the face of extraordinary
repression
we discussed matters as well related to
the People's Republic of China we
welcome the United Kingdom's commitment
to deepening its engagement in the
indo-pacific
we look forward to continuing our close
consultation on a host of issues in the
region including maintaining patient
stability across the Taiwan Strait
we also support the United Kingdom's
increased focus on National Security
risks to the sensitive technology
sectors
in recent days the United Kingdom has
denied export licenses to Research
Laboratories funded by Foreign defense
companies and block the transfer of
sensitive intellectual property
our conversation also touched on
Northern Ireland
I affirmed President Biden's unequivocal
support for the Belfast Good Friday
agreement which over the past 25 years
has been integral to preserving peace
stability and prosperity for the people
of Northern Ireland the United States
believes that there must be a negotiated
settlement to the implementation of the
Northern Ireland protocol that's
acceptable to all sides and were
heartened that in recent days the United
Kingdom and the European Union have made
some sort of progress toward a
negotiated solution
last month we appointed Joe Kennedy as
our new special Envoy of Northern
Ireland for economic affairs
a career public servant Joe will draw on
his extensive experience to support
economic growth in Northern Ireland and
to deepen our nation's people-to-people
ties with all communities
um this September it will mark an
important occasion in our own special
relationship the 75th anniversary of the
UK U.S Fulbright program it's supported
over those years more than 27 000
students Scholars professionals spanning
disciplines from Art and Science to
history to mathematics as they travel
between our countries and learn from and
grow with one another
that bond between our people is the
Beating Heart of this relationship it's
carried us through challenging times
it's created opportunities and
Innovation for the benefit of both of
our people and I might add for the world
I know that it will keep us connected
closer than ever this year and in the
years to come and with that James what
are you
Tony thank you very much I'm delighted
uh to pay my first official visit to
Washington as foreign secretary as you
said we've had plenty of opportunities
to meet and work together over the last
few months since my appointment in
multilateral four where we reinforce so
often our respective positions and I am
incredibly grateful to secretary blinken
for this opportunity to discuss a wide
range of foreign policy issues and to
reaffirm the unbreakable friendship and
enduring alliance between the United
Kingdom and the United States of America
now as it happens we are meeting on the
80th anniversary of a Casablanca
conference in January 1943 where Winston
Churchill and President Roosevelt and
their respective military Chiefs General
Allenbrook and General Marshall planned
the liberation of Europe and planned the
victory over aggression
and a secretary blinker said the main
subject of our talks today was Ukraine's
current struggle against aggression in
our time
from the onset of this crisis Britain
and America have worked hand in glove to
help our Ukrainian friends defend their
Homeland against Putin's Putin's
aggression
Ukraine's heroic armed forces have
liberate liberated thousands of square
miles and I have no doubt they can win
in their battle for freedom
as you will have seen Britain has
decided to accelerate our support
including the supply to Ukraine of main
battle tanks heavy artillery and other
military systems
it's actually blink and I are hugely
encouraged not just by the unity between
our two countries but the transatlantic
Unity between the United States and
Europe and the support from Nations uh
or on every uh continent
almost a year after Russia's uh attack
against Ukraine which broke the
fundamental principles of international
law
and we see them committing acts of
barbarism wherever they advance
what we see is dozens of countries
supplying Ukraine with weapons and
enforcing sanctions against Russia and I
pay particular tribute to the United
States of America the largest military
and economic donor to our friends in
Ukraine reinforcing this country's
long-standing to Commitment
long-standing commitment to protecting
freedom and opposing tyranny
wherever it is its ugly head
and while three quarters of the entire
membership of the United Nations voted
to condemn uh this invasion
we should remember that never in living
memory has Russia been more isolated and
the Atlantic Alliance more united if
Putin believed that the world would
succumb to Ukraine fatigue and lose the
will to resist his Ambitions then that
was once again a another colossal
misjudgment on his part
as Tony said we also discussed the
situation in Iran where the regime has
committed a cowardly and shameful act by
executing a British Iranian dual
National alireza akbari
I'm very grateful to the United States
of America for publicly condemning the
execution and for secretary blinken
expressing his condolences in our
meeting a few moments ago
and also our two countries stand with
the Brave and dignified people of Iran
as they demand their rights to live free
of Terror and oppression
in the UK has sanctioned those involved
with the execution of Mr akbari and
those involved in the oppression of
their own people including the Iranian
prosecutor general for years Iran's
leadership have inflicted Bloodshed on
their Regional neighbors by arming and
supporting military
extremists and militias now Iran has
gone further and supplied Russia with
the drones that were used to kill
civilians in Ukraine and the UK will
join with the U.S and other allies to
hold the Iranian regime to account for
the violations or the rights of their
own people
and by making themselves accomplices
to Putin's assault on Ukraine
another threat to the International
Peace and security comes from Iran's
nuclear program which has never been
more advanced and the US and UK are
determined that Iran must never acquire
a nuclear weapon
we also discussed China's growing
assertiveness on the world stage which
poses a systematic challenge to many of
our values and interests and we
recognize the need to manage competition
with China including through diplomacy
and engagement and we spoke of the need
to enhance with our allies and Friends
our respective Economic Security and we
also need to take a Long View
strengthen our resilience and reduce
strategic dependencies but nor can we
ignore China or the need to engage with
it given China's significance on every
issue in world affairs ranging from
economic stability to climate change
Britain and America share a steadfast
commitment to peace and Security in the
indo-pacific and the orcas partnership a
decade-long project to provide a
nuclear-powered conventionally armed
submarine capability to Australia is
only possible because of the unique Bond
of trust between us we also spoke about
Northern Ireland and our negotiations
with the EU and our efforts to resolve
the issues of the Northern Ireland
protocol and we recognize the interest
that the president of the United States
has on this on this issue and its desire
which is shared of course by us to see
the institutions of the Northern Ireland
back up and running
in all these areas and indeed many
others Britain and America are working
in concerts in the greatest tradition of
our alliance and I thank you secretary
blink and once again for the opportunity
to discuss these issues here in
Washington thank you well now turn to
questions we'll start with Andrea
Mitchell of NBC News
thank you very much gentlemen Mr
secretary
first I do want to ask you both about
Ukraine but first let me just ask you
because while you were at the state
department not at the White House in the
vice president's office you were for two
years the managing director of the Penn
Biden Center and just ask if you're
aware of any reason why classified
documents would have been packed and
brought there
while you were there and whether you
would be available for an interview if
the special counsel requests
uh the short answer is no just as you
heard from President Biden about a week
ago I was surprised to learn that there
were any government records taken to the
the Penn Biden Center I had no knowledge
of it at the time the White House of
course has indicated that the
administration is cooperating fully with
the review that the justice department
is undertaken and I of course would
cooperate fully with without reviewing
myself
thank you on Ukraine the world has been
horrified by what happened in Juniper
over the weekend and
this brutal attack only reinforces
President zielinski's requests for more
weapons including long-range missiles
from the United States tanks fighter
jets
attacks you know obviously Apaches
whatever else they need the secretary
the foreign secretary has said that we
need to go further and faster and give
them what it takes to win
um why has the United States not
provided
more of these long-range weapons more of
these systems and Mr foreign secretary
the U.S has said that they were
concerned about that they are concerned
about Russia's response about provoking
a further escalation is that not a
concern for Great Britain or do you
think that that is overstated and that
there is a greater need as you have
certainly expressed by your own actions
thank you Mom
I'm happy to kick it off Andrew thank
you
um
first I think it's important to
say that as this aggression has evolved
so too has our assistance to uh to
Ukraine making sure that it has what it
needs
to meet the aggression head-on and as I
said before that started long before the
Russian aggression when we saw the storm
clouds gathering in the in the months
before the aggression
we initiated what we call drawdowns of
our own military equipment to Ukraine to
make sure that it had on hand what it
would need if Russia went through with
the aggression so Stingers javelins all
of those were provided initially around
Labor Day a year ago and then again
before before Christmas so this is
months before the Russian aggression the
result of that was that one Russia went
in when they attacked the ukrainians had
on hand what they needed to repel the
effort to take Kiev to take the whole
country and then of course the war has
evolved the aggressions revolved it
moved to the the South and the East and
that's where it's been but if you look
at the trajectory from Stingers to
javelins to high Mars to Bradley
Fighting vehicles to Patriot missile
batteries we have continuously provided
uh What uh what Ukraine needs and we're
doing it in a way
make sure that it's responsive to what's
actually happening on the battlefield as
well as projecting where it might go
making sure as well that the ukrainians
are trained on the systems that were
provided that they have the ability to
maintain the systems because if they're
not trained and the systems can't be
maintained it's not going to do you very
much good for very long so all of these
things taken together have been critical
to the success that Ukraine has had to
date it starts with their own courage
and resilience but it's certainly been
strongly supported by our two countries
and many other countries and we continue
to adapt along the way now all of that
totals
for the on the part of the United States
some 25 billion dollars in security
assistance to Ukraine uh over less than
uh less than a year
um and I would anticipate that you'll
hear more announcements in the days to
come there'll be a meeting again at the
end of the week of the so-called
Ramstein group that secretary Austin put
together to make sure that we're
coordinating security assistance among
many countries so stay tuned uh for more
on that but the bottom line is we are
determined to make sure that Ukraine has
what it needs to succeed on the
battlefield as we've said the the
fastest way
to bring this war to a just and durable
end to get to diplomacy to get to a
negotiation is to give Ukraine a strong
hand on the battlefield that's exactly
what we're doing last thing I'll say
just because I have the opportunity to
address this
there had been
um a narrative the Russians were trying
to push for many weeks and many months
that they're interested in diplomacy
Ukraine and and we are not that of
course isn't entirely false but I think
you only have to look uh at Putin's own
words in a recent conversation with
president erdogan of Turkey in which he
says unless and until Ukraine accepts
the new territorial realities as he put
it there's nothing to negotiate in other
words unless and until Ukraine
acknowledges and accepts the fact that
territory that Russia seized by force
it's not getting back there's nothing to
negotiate that of course is in and of
itself a non-starter
um Andrew look I I said in in my uh
opening remarks I'm going to reinforce
it here we should never lose sight of
the fact that United States of America
is the single largest donor of military
and economic aid to support Ukraine's
self-defense of any country in the world
and UK is very proud to be uh number two
in that pecking order
um and it's very easy to get focused on
individual equipment types
um and of course tanks are the headline
of today but in our uh package of
Military Support uh there were
Heavy Artillery the as90 system and the
M109 system the the 105 the 155 caliber
guns as well as 105 caliber guns as well
as a
2000 rounds of artillery ammunition
millions of rounds of small arms
ammunition that was part of the package
that we put forward
but we should also recognize the
importance of the Patriot missile system
this is a an incredibly sophisticated
and important piece of air defense
equipment we
seen the Horrors
that Ukraine is having to endure because
of air attacks and so those air defense
missile systems the 50 plus Bradley
armor fighting vehicles that were
recently announced these are really
significant meaningful
um
donations to the to the military
effort from the UK's point of view we
certainly value the long-standing
commitment the United States of America
has made the contributions that we're
making in the UK both in terms of
equipment and training we do so standing
shoulder shoulder with the United States
America as we have done throughout this
I was at the the United Nations security
council meeting literally sitting next
door to secretary blinken when we uh
together warned the world of what Putin
was about to do we knew what his
intention was we provided that warning
to the world and we have both physically
and metaphorically been shoulder to
shoulder in our condemnation of Putin's
actions and our support to Ukraine ever
since and I think it's really important
the American people recognize what it's
what their own government is doing in
support of Freedom
um and in opposition to this aggression
and oppression
Nick Allen Nick Allen of the telegraph
uh question for each of you please
um for secretary blinken another
question on tanks um Germany suggested
today that uh it won't allow tanks to be
sent to Ukraine unless the US sends them
first uh what's your response to that
um and for the foreign secretary
um did you pledge today that the
Northern Ireland protocol issue will be
resolved by the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement and did you
discuss whether President Biden will
visit the UK in April
thank you so on the question of of tanks
and for that matter any weapon system
these are sovereign decisions for each
country to make
um I would note that what Germany has
done to date has been quite
extraordinary and we just have the
recent announcement they'll send
infantry fighting vehicles to Ukraine
and a patriot missile battery and that
follows a long line of other steps
they've taken that I suspect most of us
would not have thought
if not possible certainly probable just
just a year ago but these are
fundamentally decisions for each country
to make as something we respect we've
seen incredible solidarity among
countries around the world to support
Ukraine and as I mentioned secretary
Austin is going to be hosting another
meeting of all of the countries that are
involved in providing support to Ukraine
at the end of this week and I would
expect further announcements to come out
of that meeting
uh thank you we've got to the Northern
Lights protocol and the negotiations
with the European commission I did
update secretary blinken on that those
negotiations as I have said publicly
Amara sefkovic has also said publicly
have been negotiated have been conducted
in in good faith with a genuine desire
to get resolution to these important
issues and of course we always welcome
the uh you know visits from senior
members of the United States government
including of course the president
himself but I want to make it absolutely
clear that our desire to get resolution
on the issues of the Northern Ireland
protocol are because we want to see the
institutions of the Good Friday Belfast
Good Friday agreement uh up and running
we want to see devolved government in
Northern Ireland and Stormont back up
and running we want to see a free flow
of trade within the UK internal Market
whilst respecting the desire of the
European Union to protect its single
Market we do these things because they
are the right things to do not because
we are trying to
hit a particular date or anniversary we
want to get these things resolved as
soon as possible so that the people of
Northern Ireland
can enjoy full economic freedom can
enjoy the
um the relief packages that the UK
government has put in place to address
some of the issues of for example Energy
prices that have increased as a direct
result of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and we do these things for those reasons
and of course
as I say we recognize the president and
indeed the whole of the US government's
desire to see this resolution it marry
it mirrors our desire to get these
things resolved and indeed I believe uh
very strongly mirrors the European
commission's desire to get these things
resolved and we will continue working uh
hard and in that good spirit of
cooperation I'd make the point that I
have
tried to keep our negotiations uh
discrete and I think that discretion has
actually helped us get some things over
the line so you will understand that my
intention is to continue keeping
the details in those negotiations
discrete
Courtney McBride Bloomberg
thank you good afternoon you've
highlighted the evolution of security
assistance to Ukraine from the US UK and
and various allies and partners
um and said that you're doing things
that were not previously thought
possible I'm curious about what changed
what what was the motivating uh factor
that actually spurred that Beyond just
adapting to the to the changes in the
battlefield environment and also what
obstacles remain both individually and
collectively to get Ukraine to the point
of that Swift and decisive victory for
which the foreign secretary has been
advocating and then finally on on NATO
accession for Sweden and Finland which
you both said would be additive for the
alliance what role are your countries
playing in trying to expedite that
process thank you
I don't think anything has has changed
as I said
um from day one and before day one
we have sought to make sure to the best
of our ability and to the best ability
of many other friends and partners
who are determined to to support Ukraine
that we were getting to the ukrainians
what they needed when they needed it to
deal with the situation they were facing
on the ground and as we discussed just a
few minutes ago that what they've been
facing has has evolved that's what's
changed and so we've tried to make sure
that we're as responsive as quickly as
possible to the evolutions um on the
battlefield not only where it is
geographically but the kinds of things
that the the Russians are doing as well
as the kinds of things that the
ukrainians need to do to regain the the
territory that's been taken from them by
force so I think that's been the um the
evolution and again what you've seen in
just in recent recent weeks not only
from the United States and the United
Kingdom but from many other countries is
a continued commitment to make sure that
the ukrainians do have what they need
and you've seen countries in Europe
provide everything from
fighting vehicles to light light tanks
air defenses
ammunition artillery all of that
continues to come forward to the
ukrainians we're now
in in Winter they're continued to
continue to be ferocious fighting
particularly along the the Eastern Front
um
I anticipate that that will
unfortunately go on for for some time
but we are determined together as well
as with with many others to make sure as
I said the ukrainians have what they
need to
recapture regain what uh what they've
lost and to deal with the the Russian
aggression so that hasn't that hasn't
changed with regard to Finland and
Sweden and NATO
uh there's been a process an ongoing
process involving turkey Finland and
Sweden and I think that process has been
very productive in addressing some of
the concerns that the turkey has raised
about its own security and both Finland
and Sweden have taken significant steps
to address those concerns and we
anticipate that this process will move
forward in the uh in the weeks and
months ahead there's a strong consensus
among NATO countries for bringing
Finland and Sweden into the alliance
you've seen that in the extraordinary
rapid signing of the protocols the
ratification Now by 28 of 30 NATO
members of Finland and Sweden succession
and we look to the process that's
ongoing between turkey and Finland and
Sweden to move this forward and move it
forward expeditiously
well really all I can do
um is find myself reinforcing the points
that Secretary of Lincoln uh has made I
I mean in your question you said you
know other than the evolution of the
battle what has changed I mean it really
is as simple as that
um at the start of this conflict when
the ukrainians were defending themselves
against
um heavy armor attacks in urban
locations in and around uh Kiev and
urban and other places what they needed
were those small portable hand-held
anti-tank missile systems because in the
congested real estate of urban Warfare
those were the most effective weapon
systems that they could have utilized
against uh tanks and the
um the end-law systems that we provide
um manufactured in Northern Ireland by
the way as well as the javelin's systems
that the United States of America
provided our lovers
were absolutely instrumental in helping
the ukrainians defend themselves in
those urban areas as the battle then
moved to
um more attacks from the air the air
defense systems that we have
subsequently provided became key and now
we see
um more conflict in Open Spaces in open
ground in the East and the South which
therefore necessitates more maneuverist
equipment the ability to to fight a
maneuver simultaneously and that has
very much been the evolution of the
responses Secretary of Lincoln has said
the Ramstein process where we sit with
our International Friends uh members of
the NATO alliance to discuss what we can
provide what equipment is available what
equipment is ready to go on stream what
equipment the ukrainians need is is
essential then it's about providing the
right equipment at the right time so
they conduct the right kind of fighting
and of course the work that the the the
UK has done and the US is doing in terms
of
training the Ukrainian troops so that
they can be more effective with the
equipment and ammunition that we are
providing them that they can utilize our
our donations most effectively and
maintain the equipment most effectively
is also important and that process will
continue and we will evolve our support
just as the battle evolves and all I can
do is Echo the words that um secretary
blinker said about Sweden and Finland I
have absolutely no doubt they will be
incredibly effective allies
and I would make the point
that in both those countries they had a
long-standing posture
of not formally affiliating with NATO
that changed as a direct result of
Putin's invasion of Ukraine his actions
were designed to break NATO as a
defensive Alliance and what he did
instead was strengthen NATO as a
defensive Alliance add that to the
charge sheet of strategic level
miscalculations that Putin has been
making throughout this endeavor
take a final question from Robert Moore
of ITV
thanks for taking uh these questions I
wanted to follow up with a question
about Iran following the the killing of
Mr akbari I mean you've both said here
today and foreign secretary you said in
the House of Commons that you will hold
Iran to account
can you be specific about what you mean
given that these sanctions you refer to
have been in place for some time and I
wonder more broadly where this leaves
our Iran policy do we regard leaders in
tehranas legitimate interlocutors in
terms of the nuclear talks are they dead
in the water
or are they on life support or can they
be potentially
uh kept going even following the killing
of Mr akbari even following Iran's
provision of so much Weaponry to Russia
uh
the uh the execution of Mr akbari was
a politically motivated act and we acted
swiftly to sanction people involved with
it including the prosecutor General we
have already sanctioned members of the
so-called morality police and of the
um the the the the members of the
Iranian Judiciary who have been
um
involved with the
Crackdown of the legitimate protests of
the Iranian people I would make the
point that there have been around 500
fatalities
because of the Crackdown from the
Iranian regime against her own people 18
000 people arrested by the Iranian
regime and the point that I would make
is the leadership of Iran is a decision
for the Iranian p
but I would just make the simple
observation
that the Iranian people are telling
their government that they are not uh at
all happy with the situation that they
are living under and the limitations and
privations and it is in the hands of the
Iranian government to make those changes
um they call they call for us for the
for the US for us and and our friends to
live sanctions and the point that we've
made is that if they want to see those
sanctions removed they have to
fundamentally change their behavior
sadly we're not seeing any indication
that they are ready to do so and
unfortunately that is as true with our
efforts to prevent them acquiring a
nuclear weapon as it is
in the uh the Crackdown on the
protesters and the persecution of their
own people it is in the gift of the
Iranian leadership to bring about change
we will continue to act in response to
their behaviors and you'll have to
excuse me I'm not speculate about what
further measures we might take but I
said at the dispatch box just before
flying to the US that we do not limit
ourselves to the response that I have
already announced
but we will
continue to speak to Iran where we're
able to and and we hope that at some
point soon they will listen properly to
what we're saying because I don't
believe
that a country with a
multi-thousand year history
of sophistication
and art
really wants to have the international
reputation of ugliness and brutality
that Iran currently has they are
betraying their Heritage they are
objectifying uh sorry they are
oppressing their own people and the
simple message I open across is that
they should change not for our benefit
not because of what we say or do but
because their own people are demanding
that they do so
and really I can only strongly Echo what
the foreign secretary said
um we were appalled
by the execution of Mr Barry just as
we've been appalled by everything we've
been seeing on the streets of Iran over
the last months since these protests
began Mass arrests sham trials the
executions the use of sexual violence as
a tool for protest suppression
um
we uh the United Kingdom but not just us
countries around the world
are watching this seeing this and share
the revulsion that that we have and
these abuses will not go without without
consequence together with many other
countries we've been moving forward with
a variety of unilateral actions
multilateral measures using un
mechanisms to try to hold Iran to
account and that's played out in a
number of different places in a number
of different ways and it will continue
as long as necessary with regard to the
jcpoa the Iranians killed the
opportunity to come back to that
agreement swiftly many months ago there
was a an opportunity on the table that
that they rejected an opportunity that
was approved by all who are involved the
the Europeans the United States
Russia and China even at the time and so
the jcpo has not been on the agenda as a
practical matter for for many months now
um it's it's not our Focus we're focused
on what's happening in Iran we're Focus
focused on what Iran is doing in terms
of the provision of weapons to Russia to
use against innocent people and the
entire energy grid and Ukraine and of
course we're focused on its other
destabilizing activities throughout
throughout the region
um
what is also very much in our focus is
the president's commitment President
Biden's commitment that Iran never
acquire a nuclear weapon now we continue
to believe that the most effective way
to do that is through diplomacy and we
saw the results in successive diplomacy
when it comes to the original jcpoa
would put which put Iran's nuclear
program in a box and it was a terrible
mistake to have torn up that agreement
and walked away from it now we're
dealing with the results the results
include is the foreign secretary said
Iran making a very significant progress
on its on its nuclear program
and that represents an additional
challenge to the other things that Iran
is engaged in
but as I said the JCP play right now is
not is not on the table last thing I'll
say
is that when it comes to diplomacy in
general
um you tend to spend a chunk of your
diplomacy engaging with countries uh
with whom you have profound
disagreements are worse including
outright adversaries that's the nature
of what we do and the one thing uh
that's clear is that engaging in
diplomacy including
with those who are engaged in outrageous
actions is sometimes necessary to try to
advance our interests and it never takes
the word no from our vocabulary
thank you gentlemen thank you everyone
Dr conclusive press conference